>> Tucker: EVER NOTICE HOW
HEROES EMERGE?
THEY ARE NOT BORN, THEY JUST
APPEAR OUT OF NOWHERE.
THAT HAPPENED IN THIS COUNTRY.
THAT HERO WENT BY MANY NAMES.
WE CALLED HIM THE CREEPY PORN
LAWYER BECAUSE HE WAS.
OVER AT CNN THEY CALLED HIM
SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
THEY CALLED HIM A FUTURE
PRESIDENT.
>> IF THEY DECIDE A VALUE
A FIGHTER MOST, PEOPLE WOULD BE
FOOLISH TO UNDERESTIMATE MICHAEL
AVENATTI.
>> TO END THE THREAT OF THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY WELCOME
ATTORNEY MICHAEL AVENATTI.
>> NO ONE HAS TALKED TOUGHER
DIRECTLY TO DONALD TRUMP ON TV
THAN MICHAEL AVENATTI.
DONALD TRUMP IS AFRAID TO
MENTION HIS NAME.
>> MICHAEL AVENATTI IS A BEAST.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
>> HE IS A BEAST.
>> HE KEEPS POPPING DONALD TRUMP
IN THE MOUTH.
HE IS A BEAST.
JOHN MEACHAM SAID HE IS THE
FAVORITE OF THE PUBLIC.
>> I OWE MICHAEL AVENATTI AN
APOLOGY.
I SAID I HAVE SEEN YOU
EVERYWHERE.
I WAS WRONG.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS IQ TEST AND
EVERYBODY ON THAT TAPE FAILED
MISERABLE.
DON'T ISSUE THEM DRIVER'S
LICENSE.
THEY FELL FOR IT HARD.
IN A SINGLE WEEK IN MARCH OF
2018, MSNBC AND CNN AND ABC AND
CBS AND NBC NEWS INTERVIEWED THE
CREEPY PORN LAWYER A TOTAL OF
147 TIMES!
WE HAVE TO GET IN ON THAT.
WE HAVE TO INTERVIEW THE CREEPY
PORN LAWYER.
WE HAD ONLY ONE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK TO HIM IN STUDIO.
HERE'S PART OF IT.
YOU PROFITED FROM STORMY DANIELS
AND SHE IS WORKING IN STRIP
CLUBS.
YOU ARE EXPLOITING HER.
>> SIR, THIS ABSURD.
>> Tucker: WHY ARE YOU RICH AND
YOUR CLIENT IS WORKING IN
A SEEDY STRIP CLUB?
>> DO YOU KNOW HOW MUCH MONEY I
WORK.
>> Tucker: YOU POSE AS
A FEMINIST HERO AND THE ARE THE
CHANCE LET YOU GET AWAY WITH.
YOU ARE AN EXPLOITER OF A WOMAN
AND YOU SHOULD BE ASHAMED.
IT WAS NOT THE WARMEST INTERVIEW
EVER AND IT GOT MORE UNPLEASANT
OFF AIR.
WHERE IS HE NOW?
TODAY THE CREEPY PORN LAWYER MET
THE FATE SO MANY KNEW WAS COMING
TO HIM.
SENTENCEED TO 30 MONTHS IN
PRISON FOR TRYING TO EXTORT THE
SHOE COMPANY NIKE.
HE IS FACING SEVERAL SEPARATE
TRIALS INCLUDING ONE ABOUT
DEFRAUDSING STORMY DANIELS.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR CREEPY
PORN LAWYER'S PRESIDENTIAL'SAM
BITTIONS?
--AM BITTIONS.
FRANCIE THANKS FOR COMING ON.
I NEVER GLOAT OVER A MAN GOING
TO PRISON.
IT'S SAD.
I MEAN THAT.
HOWEVER, IF THERE WAS OF A GUY
WHO HAD A RENDEZVOUS WITH A CELL
IT WAS THIS GUY.
WAS THAT OBVIOUS?
>> YES, HE HAD THAT DEFENSE
ATTORNEY BLUSTER AND ARROGANCE
THAT DROVE ME CRAZY WITH THEY
WERE PERFORMING FOR AN AUDIENCE
OF 1, THEIR OWN CLIENT.
NEVER FOR THE JURY OR JUDGE.
TODAY IN COURT HE WAS SOBBING
WITH REGRET.
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
DROVE ME THE MOST CRAZY AS
A PROSECUTOR.
WATCHING THE DEFENDANT CRY AND
SOB.
WHERE WAS THAT REGRET WHEN THEY
WERE VICTIMIZING THEIR VICTIMS?
IT'S NOT LIKE I FEEL SORRY FOR
THE SHOE COMPANY.
BUT HE HAS AN EXTORTION SHIM.
NOW HE IS GOING TO PRISON.
I AM NOT SURPRISED HE HAD SUCH
A RISE AND SUCH A FALL.
>> Tucker: WHAT ABOUT THE
DIGNITY QUESTION.
THERE ARE FIGURES IN HISTORY WHO
MOUNT THE GALLOWS TO THEIR DEATH
WITHOUT CRIME.
AREN'T YOU SUPPOSED TO MAN UP
AND KEEP TEARS INSIDE?
WHAT HAPPENED TO THAT STANDARD?
>> WELL, WHERE WAS THE BEAST.
THEY ALL TALKED ABOUT HOW HE WAS
A BEAST AND PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
AFRAID OF HIM.
HE GOES INTO COURT AND ALMOST
EVERY OTHER CRIMINAL CRIES WHEN
HE HAS TO FACE THE MUSIC FOR
WHAT HE'S DONE.
>> Tucker: YES.
THERE SAY CONNECTION BETWE